hey welcome back to New Rockstars it's
me Mt and after Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 everyone is excited for what is
next for the new formation of the team
but many fans have also been wondering
what's next for our favorite butt
kicking bug who just wants to give you a
hug mantis what makes you projects could
we see mantis appear in next well let's
speculate on that speculation Nation
because just by looking at everything
that we know about Madness in the MCU
and taking into account some of her
stories from the comics we can make a
pretty strong guess about where mantis
might appear next we could potentially
see mantis appear very soon do not
forget to hit up nerd Ryan top chop so
that you can get a cool ass shirt to
wear on your body head on over to nerd
rifle shop today alright so after
Star-Lord announces his departure from
the Guardians team at the end of
Guardians 3 his half-sister mantis does
so as well and she mentions that after
spending all of her life doing what
other people like ego where the
Guardians wanted she desired to live her
own life and experience the Universe on
her own with mantis now on her own
personal Adventure away from her found
family she now has the opportunity to
appear Solo in other Marvel projects in
the future and out of all the upcoming
projects on the MCU Horizon I think the
most likely places that mantis could
appear are secret Invasion the Marvel's
Vision Quest Nova a potential eternals 2
and Captain America New World Order and
Thunderbolts that's a lot of projects so
let's get into why I believe this
starting with the Marvels we know from
the Marvel's trailers that Monica Carol
and Kamala are going to be chaotically
hopping through space via some sort of
cosmic energetic entanglement that all
three of them are experiencing likely
due to Kamala Khan's mysterious golden
bangle that seems to have strong roots
to the cree race with the second of
these Bengals apparently being wielded
by the cree accuser Dar Ben played by
actress zawi Ashton since the Marvels at
its core is a wild space adventure
centered around the mysterious Cosmic
science of jump points in the MCU mantis
running into the Marvels at one point
during their Journey could theoretically
be possible but we also should
definitely consider mantis's strong
roots to the cree race in the comic
books some religious groups like you
know the priests of Pama considered men
a mother Mary type figure that they
called the celestial Madonna the one who
would eventually give birth to a
Celestial Messiah like Mary gave birth
to Jesus in the Bible and because of
this they made sure to train Mantis at a
young age to become the ultimate martial
arts badass so during the course of
mantis's journey of self-discovery in
the MCU we could for sure see her come
across these religious creep priests and
they could potentially teach her more
about her Celestial potential I mean she
is the daughter of a Celestial through
ego of The Living Planet so the window
for a mantis Celestial Madonna storyline
is still very much open in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe especially during the
Multiverse Saga as king the Conqueror
has shown a strong interest in using the
celestial Madonna as a tool to help him
conquer in the comics but anyways the
next announce MCU projects that we could
potentially see mantis pop up again are
in both secret Invasion and Captain
America New World Order now I know this
sounds weird and it feels super unlikely
considering that both secret Invasion
and Captain America 4 have very
earth-centric narratives however once
the world learns that aliens are
kidnapped people to shape-shift into and
replace massive amounts of alien
xenophobia might grip the entire planet
Earth Thunderbolt Ross might just end up
spearheading that super reactionary
Global fear of all aliens in the cosmos
as president by the end of secret
Invasion if this happens any alien
immigrants to the planet could
potentially be unethically detained by
agents of Sword even aliens like mantis
who will probably likely want to revisit
Earth sometime to either soak in the
sights or just hang out with her brother
for a while and if you think about it
sword very likely has mantis on a list
somewhere after she kicked a bunch of
human butts after her alien spaceship
caused a neighborhood Panic the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
if this happened I would honestly love
to see mantis recruited to the
Thunderbolts I feel like she would make
a fantastic addition to that team
Star-Lord too but even if we don't end
up seeing mantis return in any of those
previously stated slated projects
definitely expect her to return for both
the announce Avengers movies Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars those movies are
very much expected to be all hands on
deck events like the last two Avengers
movies were so I would very much
anticipate 8 mantis and star-lord's
return then a lot of people ask me how
I'm able to stay focused researching all
these videos and honestly it's this
One-Shot energy choose are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
and everyone really
[Music]
chew you should grow they make Energy
Chews and focus choose the focus choose
are my go-to but it just depends on what
you need each energy has 75 milligrams
of pure caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional nootropics to give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew Focus choose
really help me concentrate and give me a
natural boost of energy with B C D and E
vitamins plus zinc to help with the
immune system support and the amino acid
tyrosine both Energy Chews and focus
shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus that you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals get
started with one shot energy today by
going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off of your order
that's one shot energy dot com slash new
rockstars for 10 off but now let's talk
about those MCU projects that have been
announced but not officially slayed
projects like the upcoming Nova project
which would be a great way for mantis to
appear on the scene once again we don't
know much about this project yet since
it's still being developed but we do
know from the beginning of Avengers
Infinity war that xandar the capital
planet of the overall Nova Empire was
decimated by Thanos in the black order
but we also know that since the planet
of xandar was just one planet in the
Nova Empire Richard Ryder's story of
Nova could potentially take place on any
of those planets that the Nova Empire
has already taken I can definitely see
Manchester Nova briefly teaming up in a
Nova series because although mandis's
goal is to become more independent she's
still a galactic Guardian at her core
much like Nova is so she would for sure
step in to help anyone in need if not in
a Nova project I can also see mantis's
antennas making a cameo envision's
upcoming project Vision Quest little is
known about the Vision Quest production
as of this moment but given the massive
identity crisis that we left white
Vision with the MCU before he flew out
that West View Library we can glean that
this follow-up series to One Division
will also be a journey of self-discovery
or Vision this being the case Vision
Quest would be a fantastic vehicle for
mantis's story to continue as well
especially given that these two
characters have historically had a close
relationship in the comics there could
be a possibility here that Marvel
Studios is setting up a bit of a
temporary rebound relationship for
vision with mantis for the express
purposes of them learning from each
other and growing more as individual
people because if you think about it
both mantis and vision are beings who
were originally made to be tools or
super evil people but were repurposed to
serve alongside Heroes but up until this
point both of them have never really had
the chance to experience the universe as
their own people you know without being
told what to do by the guardians or The
Avengers finally at MCU product that I
could definitely see mantis playing a
major role in could potentially be the
sequel to eternals and though an
eternals 2 project has yet to be
officially announced you can definitely
count on erosion the judge and the rest
of the celestials to shake up the MCU in
a big way very soon because if you
remember at the very end of the eternals
movie erish gym is still very much
debating whether or not to annihilate
the entire planet earth based on the
data stored in the eternal's memories
however mantis being the daughter of a
Celestial in the MCU and the revered
Celestial Madonna from the Marvel Comics
could potentially have a strong voice of
influence amongst the celestial race
while the eternals have authority in
their own way they've always been
treated like robots to be recycled by
their Celestial creators so the eternals
pleased to spare Earth might fall on
deaf ears however if a hybrid crossbreed
between celestials and Mortals recently
experienced the richness of humanity or
to intervene on behalf of Earth mantis
could single-handedly save the entire
human race and become a sort of
celestial Messiah herself and with her
Celestial brother Peter now chilling on
Earth as well mantis and Star-Lord could
potentially speak for the celestials
together defense of the planets they
love but yeah those are the MCU products
that mantis will most likely appear in
next I need Mantis to come back
immediately because she's my favorite
guardian and I'm going to miss her
dearly but anyways like always thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me at mastertamin on Twitter
because what I see between some weird
and do not forget to hit up nerd
riot.shop so that you can pick up a new
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 shirt
today those shirts are amazing you have
amazing designs for you and everybody
that you love in your family so pick up
a Guardians 3 shirt today and I'll see
you guys next time bye
[Music]
thank you